over the course of the evening you've
seen performances of the year's five
best original song songs once again here
are the nominees I can't let you throw
yourself away from Toy Story for music
and lyric by Randy Newman
[Applause]
Rocketman music by Elton John there
I'm standing with you from breakthrough
music America by Diane Warren
into the unknown from frozen to music
and lyric person stand up from Harriet
music and lyrics by Joshua
and the Oscar goes to Sir Elton John and
Bernie Taupin
first Oscar and nomination for Bernie
Taupin this is the second Oscar in
fourth nomination for Elton John
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow this doesn't suck
uh I'll be brief okay Thank You Academy
fellow nominees bless you all
congratulations Paramount Pictures Jim
you guys have been first class all the
way through this this needless to say
most of this goes to the people that
were involved in Rocket Man a little bit
of this is in every one of their hearts
David Furnish your tenacity and
dedication has driven this train all the
way here
Heather Tarpon you have my back 24 hours
a day your beauty grace good humor just
I love you alright and being here with
this guy I don't even know I don't have
words for it I mean this is this is just
justification for 53 years of just
hammering it out and doing what we do
thank you Charlie Georgie I love you
you live here I gotta be very quick
because we're going overtime
thank you to Bernie who has been the
constant thing in my life when I was
screwed up when I was normal he's always
been there for me David I love you so
much Matthew Vaughn
Taron Egerton what a performance Giles
Martin for the music Matt still Greg
Kurstin
everybody involved in Rocket Man
Paramount Pictures Jay I mean just
amazing I'm gonna leave somebody out who
if I left out anyway I'm taking too much
time this is a dream for us we've never
been nominated before for anything like
this thank you to the Academy
thank you but thank you to my fellow
nominees for all the great work you do
there's some amazing talent in this room
tonight and Wow and to my beautiful boys
who are watching this in Sidney Zachary
and Elijah how much do I love you love
you daddy loves you bye
[Applause]